hey guys I'm just this is game sweat
knees and it is International Women's
Day so do me a favor and go tell a
wonderful woman in your life that you
appreciate her and with the news first
up I happen to have a story about some
particularly kick-ass women all ready to
head up the next uncharted entry the
upcoming uncharted standalone game
uncharted the lost legacy puts the
spotlight on Nadine and the love of my
life Chloe but that's not all the game
contains the largest level the developer
Naughty Dog has ever made for an
uncharted game designer James Cooper
told Game Informer geographically it's
much bigger than Madagascar which was
previously our largest level Game
Director Kurt mark and I added that
there will be more collectibles and new
weaponry extra encounters and special
triggers for dialogue between characters
The Lost legacies locations will all
have unique themes and we're told the
Jeep and winch tool from uncharted 4 are
making a return lolly dog also revealed
that they considered other character
combos for Lost legacy but ultimately
decided that Nathan's daughter Cassie
would be too young and Sully too old to
be included The Game Informer article
indicated that the lost legacy will
revolve around Chloe and Nadine's
pursuit of a jewel that was created to
honor the Hindu god Ganesh
although the Lost legacy is standalone
it will grant access to uncharted fours
multiplayer and survival modes and those
who bought uncharted 4 Digital Deluxe
Edition all the Explorers back will get
it for free if all that talk of
Uncharted has you worried about how
you're going to fit it on your ps4 a
hard drive not to worry as external hard
drives support is being added tomorrow
the ps4 4.5 update that adds external
hard drive support boost mode and a host
of other features we'll go live tomorrow
boost mode aims to improve the quality
and performance of games that haven't
been patched for ps4 pro support
according to Sony this can provide a
noticeable framerate boost to some games
with variable frame rates and can
provide framerate stability for games
that are programmed to run at 30 or 60
hurt depending on the game the increased
CPU speed may also result in shorter
load times psvr is also getting some
improvements with tweaks to increase the
resolution of this
system screen displayed on the TV and a
jump from 90 Hertz to 124 cinematic mode
if your screen size is set to small or
medium there are also updates to voice
chat for remote play on PC Mac and
Xperia devices and a new notification
shaped like a smart phone that will pop
up when someone is sewn into PSN but not
from their console you can check out the
full list of features coming in the ps4
4.5 update in a story on GameSpot
finally if you picked yourself up a
Nintendo switch you've probably noticed
it doesn't support Netflix
well Nintendo weighed in on that one
Nintendo of America president Reggie
fils-aime a has confirmed that Nintendo
is in discussions with Netflix Hulu and
Amazon to bring their streaming services
to switch that's the good news
the bad news is we have no idea when
that will be
Fiza may told The Washington Post we
built the Nintendo switch to be a
world-class gaming device meaning we
want you first and foremost to play
games on the system and have an
incredibly fun experience we're talking
to a range of companies about other
services in our view these are not
differentiated what differentiates us is
the way you play with Nintendo's switch
and what you can play thus which also
doesn't feature a web browser but this
also may be added in the future that is
everything I've got for you today do
leave me a comment down below head to
GameSpot for all the latest news and
features hit that subscribe button if
you liked today's video and I'll see you
tomorrow